but as einstein said if you want to live  a happy life  tie it to a goal  not to people  not to things  and the reason that he said that  people and things they change you've got  no control over them at the end of the  day the only thing you really control is  yourself at the end of the day the only  thing that you can hope for  is to be going after something that has  meaning  something that has purpose something  that really gives you a reason for being  that directs your actions that becomes  the filter by which you judge everything  that really becomes the center the  gravitational center of your own  universe  but it's the goal  not the path so what is it that you  really want you have to identify that to  me everything in life  everything in life starts with the goal